[Música]
hola mi nombre es césar lópez yo soy
músico llevo
20 años recorriendo el país de arriba a
abajo
traje hoy los mismos tenis con los que
he caminado por veredas
o ríos montañas visitado cárceles o
encontrado distintas realidades del país
todas conectadas sobre todo con las
emociones y es eso de lo que quiero
hablar hoy
estábamos en la dorada caldas
y una mujer me comparte su historia los
paramilitares entren a su casa a la
medianoche sacan a su esposo en frente
de su hijo pequeño y se lo lleva
pasan los días
y ella empieza a tener problemas de
dinero
y precisamente por eso decidí empezar a
lavar la ropa de las vecinas en el río
la miel un día estando lavando la ropa
de las vecinas en el río la miel tiene
que ver el cadáver de su esposo que
viene bajando flotando en el río
lo reconoce por la mejor camisa que
tenía puesta
ella decide desde ese día que lleva una
camisa al río cada viernes la unta de
río la junta de su esposo la pone en una
piedra al sol espera que se seque
se la pone y dice que siente que su
esposo la vuelve a abrazar
y quiero empezar contando esa historia
que me contó una valerosa mujer a la
orilla de un río hace muchos años
no solo para hacerle un homenaje a ellas
sino también
para decir qué
ya sé en lo más profundo de la sabiduría
de nuestro país
la respuesta a todos nuestros problemas
la fórmula que aprendimos de cómo íbamos
a sanar el planeta dice necesitamos
llevar la mayor cantidad de gente
posible lo más rápidamente posible al
nivel más alto de conciencia posible y
siempre que hemos hablado de esa
ecuación pensamos y quién nos va a guiar
quien nos va a guiar a tantos tan rápido
más arriba
la conclusión a la que yo personalmente
he llegado
es que precisamente en esa historia que
cuento para empezar esta conversación
está la respuesta
el dolor
la carencia el obstáculo la tragedia
y han sido en la humanidad nuestros
grandes maestros por eso en las víctimas
de la violencia de este país es que yo
encuentro permanentemente las respuestas
para salir de lo que estamos viviendo
porque en ellas anida
el perdón profundo la reconciliación
urgente y necesaria pero sobre todo han
tenido la oportunidad de hacer un ciclo
de sus emociones y es ahí donde estoy yo
en el arte el arte como la posibilidad
de transformar y sanar todas nuestras
emociones
siempre que entro a una cárcel que veo a
un muchacho y que conversó con él y que
él ha matado a alguien y me dice yo
sabía que matar a alguien estaba mal yo
sabía que dispararle a alguien tenía un
peso jurídico que ha dañado a una
familia pero estaba atravesado por una
rabia ira se los deseos de venganza
resentimiento
y porque si somos capaces de identificar
que en las emociones o que somos seres
emocionales y que de allí parten las
decisiones de las guerras y también lo
que hoy está viviendo colombia
porque los artistas no estamos haciendo
mucho más para tramitar esas emociones
estoy seguro de que justo antes de
gatillar un revolver de hundir un puñal
hay un instante en el que hay una
decisión de hacerlo pero hay un instante
previo donde lo que se sucede es una
emoción y si nosotros lográramos entrar
por esa ventana de los milésimas de
segundo antes a esa acción
podríamos sin lugar a dudas transformar
la historia de este país por eso me mi
proyecto de vida está ofrendado
completamente andar con esta guitarra
para arriba para abajo cantando tocando
escuchando tratando de ser útil para la
sanación de esas emociones y es triste
decirlo pero las artes no son ni han
sido la prioridad nunca en este país
siguen siendo la vocacional
en las escuelas sigue siendo el 0.03 del
producto interno bruto de este país
si nosotros entendiéramos que las artes
complejizan al ser humano nos pueden
mostrar que no somos ni los buenos ni
los malos sino que somos todos que somos
esclavos en algún momento un interés de
una emoción de una circunstancia
el arte hace memoria que reconstruye no
solo los datos de lo que nos tuvimos que
vivir en esta guerra sino que además
conserva las emociones para sanarlas y
que no se repitan que el arte además es
el puente que pone a los opuestos a que
se encuentren como una autopista
virtuosa que permite ese encuentro de
opuestos porque se reconocen sujetos
culturales
se han comido de la misma comida que han
tenido el mismo abuelo arriero que han
tenido la misma música en sus oídos
que el arte educa una generación de
chicos y chicas no para enseñarles las
capitales los ríos sino que el arte les
educa en la empatía en la compasión en
la capacidad de entender a ese otro a
esa otra que tiene dificultades y
entonces estaríamos sacando de las
escuelas niños y niñas capaces de tomar
decisiones que traen la paz
el arte para devolverle el corazón a la
política
el arte para inventar un universo nuevo
posible un universo donde quepamos y
podamos inventar nuevas fronteras nuevas
formas
nuevos caminos
es por eso que yo estoy aquí que mi
esfuerzo ha sido dedicado a encontrar
respuestas y yo tengo que decirles hoy
qué tal vez tres de las claves que
enfocan todo mi trabajo son uno hay que
derrocar y destronar y destruir
el machismo
lo que yo puedo ver la mitad de la selva
cuando hay dos frentes disparando o
puedo ver en una esquina de cualquier
ciudad de colombia cuando dos
conductores se enfrentan o puedo ver en
medio del paro nacional
son los masculinos entrenados para
demostrarse mutuamente que son capaces
de hacerle más daño al otro que el que
el otro le puede hacer al otro y están
enfrascados en eso porque así crecieron
así fueron formados nuestras
masculinidad es tienen tres diría yo
características 1 crecimos siendo
hombres que pensaban que eran superiores
a las mujeres porque en la casa no
servían un poquito de comida más grande
en un plato
porque si la plata estaba contaditas
favorecían al hombre para que fuera a
estudiar y no a la niña porque las
hermanitas lavaban nuestros bluyines
dormían todas juntas en un cuarto para
dejarnos el cuarto más grande a los
varones
porque nos dijeron que lo que nos hacía
hombres era nuestra fuerza física y
entonces nos fuimos a los parques a
hacer barras
y sobre todo salimos a demostrarle a los
otros hombres los hombres que somos
cuando imponemos por la fuerza nuestra
idea o nuestra realidad
y sobre todo hombres que crecimos
bloqueando nuestra parte femenina la
incapacidad absoluta de conectar con la
sensibilidad del cuidado
con la sensibilidad de la creatividad
concentro mi trabajo en derrotar en
destronar los modelos de éxito jóvenes
que se educaron pensando que lo único
que valía en la vida era conseguir plata
y que si usted no consigue plata
suficiente su proyecto de vida no fue
exitoso y entonces como el sistema
privilegia el que consiguió 100 mil
igual que tienes 1000
la desesperación de los jóvenes de
barriada en las comunas o incluso de los
empresarios es acumular y tener más
moneda
y esa moneda se consigue a veces de
manera justa con un digno trabajo pero
también se consigue de maneras
y legales
causando daño
en una presión que reciben los muchachos
de tener que validarse socialmente
teniendo una buena moto unos buenos
tenis un nuevo teléfono y eso se hace
agrediendo a otros y a otras y ahora
entonces la moneda de cambio no serán
los pesos sino que serán los views los
likes porque es lo que determina que yo
sea
importante valioso y yo tengo que decir
que yo conozco en la vida a gente que no
tiene un celular que no tiene una cuenta
en instagram en twitter en facebook y es
profundamente valiosa exitosa que tiene
un proyecto de servicio que tiene un
proyecto conectado con los sueños con la
creatividad que cuida de un árbol que lo
ve florecer y dar fruto
varias veces al año y que eso lo hace
profundamente exitoso y por último yo
tendría que decir que los artistas
estamos llamados a recordarle a esta
especie humana
que no está ahí ni en el centro ni por
encima ni por fuera de las otras
inteligencias de las otras especies
que todo lo que está allá afuera no está
para mi servicio un río un animal una
montaña sino que tengo que convivir de
manera armónica y pareja con otras
realidades inteligencias especies que
merecen tanto como yo ser cuidadas
respetadas
y reconocidas
entonces esta es mi lucha esta es mi
razón de ser y yo lo único que tengo hoy
para compartirles a ustedes son cada vez
nuevas preguntas las preguntas que he
adquirido con estos huecos en la suela
de mis zapatos recorriendo este país
tratando de ver cómo más desde este
instrumento desde esta vocación
podemos arrebatarle por lo menos una
victoria la violencia
y en estos tiempos de tanto dolor en
estos tiempos que le han generado tanto
dolor a este país donde hoy mientras
estamos grabando esta charla hay
familias hay mamás buscando hijos
hay gente sanando heridas
nuestra resistencia tiene que ser aún
mayor y nuestro compromiso con abrir
canales de diálogo y con explorar las
emociones y las nuevas sensibilidades es
todavía superior
aquí voy a estar hasta el último aliento
como lo aprendí en el año 97 en mogotes
cuando lln se tomó el pueblo
y los campesinos salieron y se tomaron
de las manos e impidieron que se
destrozará el pueblo y se llevaran a la
gente tomados de las manos diciendo
qué estás dispuesto a dar por tu
comunidad
hasta la vida
hasta cuándo vas a estar aquí
resistiendo por dignidad frente a tu
pueblo siempre
hasta la vida y siempre
este es mi canto para resistir a la
violencia y voy a compartirles la
canción que hicimos no solo para
recordar a nuestros muertos sino porque
es precisamente lo que ellos quisieron
cuando dispararon contra otra persona
que desapareciera su vida que
desapareciera su idea que desapareciera
su postulado que desapareciera su nombre
así que con este canto hoy yo vengo a
arrebatarle esa pequeña victoria a los
violentos nombrándolos en esta canción
que se llama hasta que amemos la vida
[Música]
bernardo fueron temístocles machado
bernardo jaramillo álvaro gómez hurtado
[Música]
yamilé guerra
y josé antequera
lara bonilla y de la patria orlando
sierra
jaime garzón maría del pilar hurtado
diego felipe becerra y dylan cruz
marchando desarmados manuel cepeda luis
carlos gala
eduardo umaña mendoza diana turbay si
nos quedamos callados nos matan y si
hablamos también
y
i
dijo christina bautista
antes de caer
como mario calderón como el salvado como
pardo real como carlos pizarro
volveré a callar y volveré a llorar
y volver a indignarme esta realidad
[Música]
y entonces volveré a pararme volveré a
salir ya marchar y exigir con el alma
encendida
[Música]
hasta que amemos la vida
hasta que amemos dar
[Música]
i
alfredo correa de andréis
silvia de usar y ocho niños bombardeados
en el caquetá
y la guardia indígena perdió a nelly
bernal alexander parra de dimas torres y
casi 300 firmantes de la paz gilberto
echeverri
guillermo gaviria yo sé diputados en
manos de la guerrilla alfonso reyes
echandía sin olvido cristina guarín y
los 'falsos positivos' sumaron más de
diez mil
mateo y margarita natalia y rodrigo
guillermo cano y con él el periodismo
digno guadalupe salcedo jorge eliécer
gaitán y más de seis mil almas de la uc
que ya no están
[Música]
y nunca
siempre abrazar y querer
duele la escombrera la escuela general
santander
hay que encontrar la verdad hay que
buscar la salida
[Música]
hasta que amemos la vida
hasta que el memo
[Risas]
[Música]